[Applaus]
[Musik]
hier ist die millionen dollar frage
warum will putin einen offenen krieg in
der ukraine oder zumindest warum will
putin das den nato denkt er wolle allen
krieg in der ukraine es mag
offensichtlich erscheinen aber ich bin
mir sicher dass nicht viele von euch
wissen wie sie auf diese frage antworten
sollen seht es mal so russland geht es
wirklich dreckig so wie die dinge im
moment stehen könnte man sagen dass das
land seit der invasion der krim in einer
wirtschaftskrise steckt und die lieber
im jahr 2014 wenn der wirtschaftskrise
sagen meinen wir damit ein echtes
debakel mit zuständen nahe der
hyperinflation hinzu kommen noch die
wirtschaftssanktionen die immer noch in
kraft sind und die tatsache dass ein
offener krieg mit der ukraine bedeuten
würde dass das land fast alle seiner
gaskunden verlöre
[Musik]
auch visa politik haben wir schon zig
mal über die abhängigkeit europas von
russischem gas gesprochen aber diese
abhängigkeit hat auch eine kehrseite
europa ist ja auch russlands bester
kunde es nützt einem er nichts auf
riesigen gasreserven zu sitzen wenn man
sie nicht verkaufen kann und
gleichzeitig eine hungernde bevölkerung
und eine aufgeblähte armee durch zu
fördern hat mit anderen worten die
russische wirtschaft verfügt kaum noch
über spielräume irgendwelche risiken
einzugehen aber dann stellt sich
wiederum die frage warum ausgerechnet
die ukraine was könnte putin gewinnen
wenn er die ukraine kontrolliert
natürliche ressourcen davon gibt es kaum
etwas in diesem land das flächenmäßig
fast doppelt so groß ist wie deutschland
reichtum führende unternehmen ganz und
gar nicht die ukraine ist das größte
land in europa oder anders gefragt wäre
es nicht besser wenn putin sich auch
sein eigenes land konzentrieren würde in
letzter zeit habt ihr zweifellos die
bizarrsten erklärungen für putins
truppenaufmarsch an der grenze zur
ukraine gehört
manche gehen soweit putin mit den
protagonisten einer lateinamerikanischen
seifenoper zu vergleichen einer jener
eifersüchtigen männer der zu seiner ex
frau sagt wenn ich dich nicht haben kann
dann soll sich niemand haben aber machen
wir uns nichts vor der internationalen
politik ist dann doch etwas komplexer
als eine soap versteht uns nicht falsch
die auf diese art politik für nicht
gerade die allergrößten partie fest ja
es stimmt dass wir ihn irgendwann einmal
als maskottchen des kanals benutzt haben
oder sogar witze über ihn gemacht haben
aber jeder der uns kennt weiß dass wir
von system putin alles andere als
überzeugt sind in diesem video liegen
wir daher da was russland erzählt und
was die wahren gründe für einen
möglichen krieg sind dazu sind wir in
der lage weil wir abgesehen von unserer
eigenen redaktionellen linie unabhängig
sind ja dieser kanal wird von niemandem
außer euch unseren förderern und
werbekunden finanziert und von denen mit
fast niemand in der inhalte rein sollte
es doch jemand versuchen gibt es von uns
nur eine mögliche antwort und tschüss
ich weiß dass nicht alle kanäle das von
sich behaupten können denn da läuft es
oft eher genau umgekehrt wer zahlt
bestimmt dort die musik wir machen
unsere musik jedoch ganz nach eigener
fasson und wer uns finanziell unter die
arme greifen möchte muss damit leben
oder eben gehen da gibt es auch
keinerlei kompromisse diese prämisse ist
absolut nicht verhandelbar und ja der
hat in der vergangenheit aus diesem
grund bereits sponsoren abgelehnt und
ich kann euch sagen dass dieses gefühl
der unabhängigkeit einfach
unvergleichlich ist ich spreche hier
nicht von risiko von der youtube
monetisieren zu werden das nehmen wir
morgen im kauf und verzichten dann eben
auf die werbeeinnahmen daran davon dass
man von irgendwo oben eine bestimmte
haltung oder meinung vorgegeben bekommt
oder gar über so wenig das gefühl
verfügt dass man sich freiwillig einer
bestimmten lage anschließt und sich dort
geborgen zu fühlen oder besser karriere
machen zu können nun ja das alles sind
ja keine neuen phänomene mitläufertum
kennen wir aus der geschichte und
gruppenzwang aus dem kindergarten und
ich denke dass ein hauptgrund warum die
einzelnen mitglieder soll politik dienst
zueinander gefunden haben und trotz
aller politischen differenzen
zusammenhalten gerade die gemeinsame
aversion gegen dinge wie optimismus
kollektivismus konformismus gruppenzwang
und mitläufertum ist wir lieben es gegen
den strom zu schwimmen und wenn der
strom irgendwann in unsere richtung
fließt drehen wir wieder um denn egal ob
einem gerade eine linke idee zusagt und
dem anderen rechte wir werden uns immer
bei dem punkt einig dass sich keine von
einem bestimmten lager vereinnahmen
lassen darf da eine solche anbiederung
die persönliche offenheit für eine
sachlich faire bewertung jeder einzelne
egal aus welcher politischen richtung
sie kommt kompromittieren würde gut was
wollen wir euch mit all dem sagen
natürlich handelt es sich wieder um
einen schlauch verpackten spendenaufruf
aber wir möchten euch auch einen kleinen
denkanstoß geben und einen anstoß zur
selbstreflektion denn das was für
journalisten gelten muss sollten auch
die konsumenten medialer informationen
beherzigen nämlich dass man immer wieder
prüfen muss ob man sich bewusst oder
auch unterbewusst zum diener einer
einseitigen vorgegebenen haltung gemacht
hat absolute objektivität und
neutralität gibt es nicht und wer dies
behauptet ist einfach nicht seriös was
ist jedoch leben kann ist eine relative
ausgewogenheit diese kann dann erreichen
wenn man ganz bewusst informationen mal
von der reinen waagschale bezieht und
mal von der anderen mit der zeit kann
man diese unterschiedlichen
informationsquellen immer besser
einordnen und die daraus versuchen
informationen gewichten und nur wenn man
viele wirklich verschiedenes rbl der
realität miteinander kombiniert gelingt
es einem der wahrheit näher zu kommen
diese aus den jeweiligen
extrempositionen zu interpolieren dazu
muss man sich natürlich aus einer bubble
seiner kämpfer sollen begeben und vor
allem begegnen können das heißt man
braucht einen unzensierten zugang zu
einem möglichst breiten meinungsspektrum
ein staat der den anspruch erhebt einer
freiheitlich demokratisch und
pluralistische grundordnung zu schützen
muss einen solchen zugang sicherstellen
und auch die mono beziehungsweise
oligopolistischen betreiber von für
meinungsbildung dienen den medien und
kommunikations plattformen zur
einhaltung dieser grundordnung
verpflichten aber achtung jedes mediums
ändert sich im laufe der zeit das zdf
der spiegel und die bild zeitung von vor
20 jahren sind nicht mehr dieselben wie
heute als konsumenten befinden wir uns
in einem nie enden wollenden kampf gegen
die manipulation deswegen dürfen wir nie
aufgeben und auch nie denken der hätten
irgendwann wir wohnen schließlich
manipulieren auch werde ich ja im sinne
unserer interessen wir wollen dass uns
dabei hilft weiter unabhängig zu bleiben
und der viele neue videos liefern zu
können und falls dies auch in deinem
hintern er legt wer also quasi ein
gemeinsames interesse haben klicke bitte
gleich auf den spenden link unten in der
beschreibung wer tanzt ihr okay ich
denke das war genug medienkompetenz
kunde für heute zurück zum eigentlichen
thema dieses videos und unserer frage
welches interesse hat russland überhaupt
an der ukraine sind die gründe für das
risiko in einen krieg einzutreten
wirklich legitim worum geht s vladimir
putin wirklich heute werden wir diese
fragen beantworten und zwar zuerst mit
einem kurzen blick in die geschichte
die große russische nation
[Musik]
was soll ich jemals gefragt woher das
wort russland kommt nun es kommt von der
alten hochs was eine föderation
hauptsächlich slawische stämme war und
jetzt ratet mal welcher stadt die
hauptstadt ist überhaupt ersten staates
auf dem gebiet der fußball moskau sankt
petersburg weit gefehlt diese beiden
städte existierten damals noch nicht mal
nein die hauptstadt war kiels deswegen
man auch von der klever ausspricht und
kiew ist heute die hauptstadt der
ukraine
mit anderen worten könnte man sagen dass
die ersten russen der geschichte ihre
kulturellen wurzeln in jenem gebiet
haben welches heute als ukraine bekannt
ist die alte russ wurde nebenbei bemerkt
zum größten staat ganz europas doch im
13 jahrhundert zerstörten die mongolen
unter dem kommando von button kann diese
situation aber warum gehen wir überhaupt
so weit in der geschichte zurück nun aus
zwei gründen
erstens weil es für uns wichtig ist die
rolle zu verstehen welche die ukraine
für die russische identität spielt alles
was ich dir im folgenden erzählen werde
ist wortwörtlich aus la die mir putins
reden entnommen falls ich im folgenden
also einen ukraine beleidigt fühle er
denkt dass ich ja fake history verbreite
das alles ist das russische narrativ
prügel also bitte nicht auf mich als
überbringer der nachricht bei der zweite
grund warum wir so weit in die
vergangenheit zurückgehen ist dass wir
verstehen müssen dass die ukraine als
nationale einheit ein sehr junges land
ist ich meine das gebiet ist die ukraine
haut ein hemd wurde von allen möglichen
medien bevölkert und partei aller
möglichen reiche tatsächlich kommt der
name ukraine von ukraine was im alt
russischen so viel die peripherie
bedeutet und dem deutschen markt
entspricht 3 heißt ja rand oder grenze
um die reine vorstellung zu geben 1569
gehörte ein großer teil dieses gebiets
zu polen litauen das ist richtig
heutzutage ist litauen ein relativ
kleines land aber in jenen jahren
umfasst fast ganz polen und einen teil
der ukraine das erklärt warum der adel
und die eliten katholisch waren im
gegensatz dazu war die creme überwiegend
muslimisch sie wurde von denen nicht nur
wegen der köstlichen remoulade berühmten
tataren besetzt übrigens wisst ihr
eigentlich ob man noch katastrophe sagen
darf oder nicht ich komme da irgendwie
nicht mehr mit was heute schon
rassistisch ist und was erst morgen gut
wie ausgemacht zumindest nach der
russischen erzählung sprach das einfache
volk in diesen ländern jedoch russisch
und kannte sich zum orthodoxen glauben
vor allem die kurse die kosten waren
eine der vielen ethnischen gruppen die
hier lebten und sie hatten zunehmend die
nase voll vom katholischen litauisch
polnischen adel und so kam es zum krieg
gegen litauen in dessen folge kiew 1686
unter die kontrolle der kosten kam das
ganze gebiet das die kosten
kontrollierten wurde malaysia genannt
also klein russland oder kleiner roos
die kosten stiegen durch ihren sieg
sozial auf und wurden in den russischen
adel aufgenommen jahrhundertelangen
wanderten tausende von ukraine nach
russland aus als wäre es ein teil ihrer
eigenen heimat um die reine vorstellung
zu geben einer der führenden
romanautoren der russischen kultur ist
nicolas gogol er hat sein ganzes leben
lang auf russisch geschrieben geboren
wurde allerdings auf dem gebiet der
heutigen ukraine erwarte ein moment denn
wir befinden uns bereits im zwanzigsten
jahrhundert und es gibt immer noch keine
nationale einheit die wir ukraine nennen
können nach der bolschewistischen
revolution sagt die landkarte
tatsächlich folgendermaßen aus
wie du sehen kannst gab es einen teil
der sowjetunion gehörte aber es gab auch
eine region in polen und eine andere in
der damaligen tschechoslowakei als die
sowjetunion gegründet wurde wollte die
republik teil der russischen republik
sein doch linien entschied von seinem
schreibtisch aus dass die teil der neuen
demokratischen republik ukraine werde
sollte die ihrerseits zur sowjetunion
gehörte mit anderen worten die ukraine
wie wir sie heute kennen entstand erst
nach dem zweiten weltkrieg damals
beschloss russland dass ein teil der
eroberten gebiete ukrainisches und nicht
russisches territorium werden sollte
aber warum fragst du dich vielleicht
wollten sie nicht dass russland größer
wird nun die wahrheit ist dass die
grenze zwischen russland und der ukraine
damals kaum eine rolle spielte überlegt
mal beide länder waren teil der
sowjetunion beide wurden von moskau aus
kontrolliert beide hatten eine russische
kultur und tradition beide teilten das
gleiche slawische blut alles andere war
nebensächlich doch 1991 wurde die
ukraine unabhängig russland war darüber
nicht im geringsten amüsiert nach
sowjetischer lesart war es russland das
die verschiedenen ethnien und regionen
zusammengeführt und zu einem einzigen
nationalen konzept vereint hatte
plötzlich nachdem all dies geschehen war
kam die ukraine und beschlossen
unabhängig zu werden
wie gesagt das alles ist die russische
perspektive sie blendet weite teile der
komplexen geschichte der ukraine zu
fahren und auf die zeit vor und nach dem
zweiten weltkrieg aus inklusive der
vielzahl damalige autonomiebestrebungen
und der brutalen gezielt ausgelösten
hungersnot den holodomor bei denen es
sich eigentlich um einen gegen die
ukrainische aber auch die kasachische
landbevölkerung gerichteten völkermord
handelte eine klassisches geschichts
wissenschaftliches problem nun ist
jedoch dass man all diese argumente auf
unendlich viele länder anwenden könnte
wie kolonisiert wurden gab es indien
schon vor der ankunft der dritten
offensichtlich nicht vor der britischen
kolonisierung war das gebiet von indien
und pakistan ein mischmasch aus
königreichen und stemmen plötzlich kam
die briten und vereinigten alles zu
einer einstigen kolonie war später
wurden die einwohner dieser kolonie
unabhängig behielten aber die von den
kolonialherren gezogenen grenzen bei das
gleiche könnte man über große teile des
nahen ostens und afrikas sagen sowie
über so gut wie jedes
lateinamerikanische land aber die frage
die eigentliche frage ist interessieren
putin wirklich so brennend historische
gründe nun nein das tun sie nicht was
also will er dann nun das werden wir uns
jetzt mal ansehen
[Musik]
worauf es wirklich ankommt
russland hat angst dass die nato
ballistische raketen auf seinem
territorium richtet schlimmer noch
russland angst davor dass die nato
atomraketen auf moskau richtet deutlich
sagst du jetzt aber die atomraketen der
nato sind doch schon längst und die
ganze zeit auf moskau gerichtet und ja
da so vollkommen recht sowohl die nato
als auch russland haben massive
atomwaffenarsenale und ballistische
raketen die auf den jeweils anderen
gerichtet sind und mit denen sie
jederzeit auf knopfdruck den ganzen
planeten gleich mehrfach für so gut wie
alle lebewesen auf tausende von jahren
unbewohnbar machen können eventuell mit
ausnahme von bärtierchen und den
geissens okay ich gebe es zu ich bin ein
kind der 80er muster in der schule die
wolke und die letzten kinder von
schaewen lesen und kann euch eines
verraten es ist nicht ganz einfach wegen
klimaerwärmung in panik zu verfallen
wenn man als kind jeden tag vor dem
drohenden nuklearen winter bitten musste
da jede sekunde über einen hereinbrechen
könnte wir alle sind eben nur das
produkt unserer grund traumatisierungen
aber ich weiß ich muss diese irrationale
panik vor dem atomkrieg reflektieren
tief durchatmen und realistisch
einordnen immerhin haben sich die
atommächte viele jahre lang gegenseitig
in schach gehalten denn niemand will
wirklich ein weltuntergang auslösen die
größte angst die wir wohl haben müssen
wäre murphys tuesday die ständig
drohende apokalypse durch ein dummes
missgeschick oder missverständnis also
davon abgesehen sind atomwaffen wollen
nicht das problem konventionelle sind da
schon ein viel realistischeres auch für
putin und gerade in der heutigen zeit
und erst recht im vergleich mit der
situation zur zeit des kalten krieges
[Musik]
denn es ist die eine sache durch
ballistische raketen in westdeutschland
2000 km von moskau entfernt rot zu
werden und eine ganz andere wenn diese
an der ukrainischen grenze in nur 700
kilometern entfernung stationiert sind
mit anderen worten russland will nicht
dass eben die nato-länder so stark auf
die pelle rücken aber glaube nicht eine
sekunde das die russen arme kleine opfer
der nato sind sie haben eine gigantische
militärbasis in kaliningrad das direkt
an polen und litauen kannst du kannst
dir vorstellen was dort alles
stationiert ist falls nicht wir haben
ein video darüber gedreht dass ich dir
verlinken werde wir müssen uns jedoch
eine sehr wichtige sache ins gedächtnis
rufen die nato ist ein militärbündnis
zum zweck der verteidigung gegen die
sowjetunion gegründet wurde und dass
sich russland heute immer mehr als erbe
der sowjetunion sieht ist sie in seinen
augen auch russlands größter widersacher
natürlich unterzeichneten sie ihnen
nutzen 90er jahren eine art friedens
erklärung versprachen dass sie niemals
militärische übungen in russlands
durchführen würden seitdem hat die nato
jedoch nicht aufgehört nach osten zu
expandieren
im jahr 1990 traten polen ungarn und
tschechien bei im jahr 2004 traten die
baltischen staaten rumänien bulgarien
die slowakei und slowenien bei mit
anderen worten die nato rückt immer
näher an russland heran aus der sicht
des kremls ist das ein verrat und ein
aggressives manöver auch sich der nato
sieht die sache natürlich ganz anders
aus all diese länder haben sich
freiwillig entschieden den bündnis
beizutreten und es ist ganz logisch dass
sie teil der nato sein wollen denn wenn
kritiker der nato osterweiterung immer
wieder betonen man müsse russlands
sicherheitsinteressen respektieren muss
man ihnen immer wieder unter die nase
reiben dass die baltischen völker die
polen tschechen slowaken ungarn rumänen
und bulgaren doch den gleichen respekt
ihrer sicherheit und vor allem ihre
souveränität verdienen oder etwa nicht
sie sind keine unter völker russlands
sie wollen nicht aus muss korrigiert
werden und haben dies auch nicht nötig
denn sie sind doch in fast allen punkten
viel erfolgreicher und habe es seit dem
fall des kommunismus viel weitergebracht
als ihre ehemalige besatzungsmacht und
die russen nach dem zweiten weltkrieg
zumeist als befreier angesehen haben
durch ihre anschließende unterdrückung
herrschaft jeglichen kredit bei diesen
völkern verspielt und sich dadurch nach
dem fall des eisernen vorhangs der nato
geradezu in die arme getrieben denn
diese wollten in erster linie ja
unabhängig sein und sich endlich selbst
regieren
machen sich jedoch auch dessen bewusst
dass sie als relativ kleine länder einem
irgendwann wieder aufgestiegenen
imperialistischen russland wehrlos
ausgeliefert wären das erklärt warum zum
beispiel alle offiziellen gebäude in
litauen neben ihren nationalen und
europäischen flaggen auch nato flagge
tragen und du wirst dich fragen
übertreiben die nicht ein bisschen warum
haben sie so viel angst vor dem heutigen
russland sie wollen das einfach für ihre
zukunft vorsorgen ihrer unabhängigkeit
langfristig sicher auch wenn die angst
vor einer möglichen russischen invasion
übertrieben erscheinen mag hat putin
seit 2010 sorgt bewiesen die real sie
ist 2014 war das ja einen putin auf der
halbinsel krim einmarschiert ist und die
unterstützung des kabarettisten in der
ost ukraine eskaliert und er tat dies
ganz einfach aus dem grund um die
ukraine als souveränen staat also
hindern einen freihandelspakt mit der
europäischen union abzuschließen und wie
hat die ukraine reagiert nur in gewisser
weise kann man sagen dass russland mit
dieser invasion viel verloren hat der
reden hier nicht nur über die sanktionen
und gegen die russische wirtschaft die
unterstützung für die nato ist so gut
wie der gesamten ukraine in die höhe
geschnellt die ukraine wollen nichts
mehr von russland hören außer diejenigen
denen östlichen regionen leben also in
so genannten don was die aktionen
moskaus in der ukraine und georgien aber
zb auch das sprengstoffanschlag auf das
tschechische munitionslager nbtc das
heißt direkt auf dem boden eines nato
staats haben gezeigt dass die
befürchtungen der nachbar völker
russlands vollkommen angebracht sind
selbst schweden und finnland erwägen
deswegen schon der nato beizutreten und
glaubt mir die aufgabe ihrer neutralität
fällt in skandinavien alles andere als
leicht es ist daher mehr als
heuchlerisch die nato-erweiterung aus
der respekt vor russland abzulehnen und
dabei die absolut natürlichen sicherheit
und souveränität interessen jener völker
die sich von moskau bedroht fühlen oder
gar wirklich schon aktiv bedroht werden
vollkommen zu ignorieren ach und dann
wäre da noch so ein argument mit denen
wir auch immer wieder in den kommentaren
unter unseren videos konfrontiert werden
dass die nato nämlich ein angebliches
versprechen an die sowjetunion brechen
würde keine staaten des ehemaligen
warschauer pakts aufzunehmen meine
lieben zuschauer ich denke es wäre
allerhöchste zeit mit diesen mythos ein
für alle mal aufzuräumen
[Musik]
das problem ist allerdings dass uns in
diesem video leider die zeit dazu fehlt
dieses ganze hochgradig komplexe und
unglaublich interessante thema die
damaligen verhandlungen um die
wiedervereinigung deutschlands und den
fall des eisernen vorhangs so zu
besprechen wie es der sache angemessen
wäre ja diese spannende geschichte hat
ein eigenes video verdient vergesst also
beträgt das abo und aktiviert bitte
jetzt auch das glöckchen um in zukunft
keines unserer videos mehr so verpassen
ich danke euch aber gut ich will euch
wenigstens ein paar anhaltspunkte geben
wieso es sich bei den angeblichen
versprechen der nicht erweiterung der
nato um einen mythos handelt der leider
immer wieder missbraucht wird erstens
die nato konnte ein solches versprechen
nie abgeben denn es würde gegen ihre
eigenen gründungsstaaten aus dem jahr
1949 verstoßen da steht es szenen des
nordatlantik vertrags besagt dass die
vertragsparteien einstimmig jeden
anderen europäischen staat in der lage
ist die grundsätze dieses vertrags zu
fördern und zur sicherheit des
nordatlantischen raums beizutragen zum
beitritt einladen können bei den
verhandlungen über die deutsche
wiedervereinigung wurden so manche
hypothetischen szenarien auf den tisch
gelegt besprochen und auch wieder
verworfen bei russischen nationalisten
beliebt ist zum beispiel der ausspruch
des damaligen außenministers moussa
james baker nicht einen zentimeter
weiter nach osten wichtig ist jedoch vor
allem der kontext in dem er das gesagt
hat und wie es von den anderen akteuren
dieser verhandlungen interpretiert wurde
der kontext war nämlich zweifelsohne die
wiedervereinigung deutschlands die idee
dass die garantien über die lösung der
deutschen frage hinausgehen sollten
wurde damals vor allem von
bundesaußenminister hans dietrich
genscher vertreten er sagte dass
veränderungen in osteuropa die stroke
ethischen sicherheitsinteressen nicht
gefährden dürften und dass die nato eine
expansion näher an die sowjetischen
grenzen ausschließen sollte allerdings
verfügt über keinerlei mandat etwas im
namen der nato oder anderer länder zu
versprechen alle beschlüsse im bündnis
müssten im konsens erfolgen genschers
standpunkt wurde also nicht von den
anderen handelspartnern übernommen und
auch nicht bestandteil irgendeines
schriftlichen abkommens der damalige
generalsekretär des zentralkomitees der
kommunistischen partei der sowjetunion
und staatspräsident der sowjetunion
michail sergejewitsch gorbatschow selbst
sagte 2014 über die gespräche dass das
thema nato erweiterungen in linearen
überhaupt nicht besprochen wurde denn
1990 funktionierte der warschauer pakt
noch so dass eine ausweitung nato auf
die postkommunistischen staaten noch gar
nicht auf der tagesordnung stehen konnte
laut alle beteiligten inklusive
gorbatschow forderten im rahmen der
sogenannten zwei plus vier gespräche
jetzt lediglich dass bis zum abschluss
des vier jahre dauernden abzug der
sowjetischen streitkräfte aus
deutschland die militärische
infrastruktur der nato nicht ausgebaut
und keine nichtdeutschen nato truppen
auf dem gebiet der ehemaligen ddr
stationiert werden sollten außerdem
sollten mit massenvernichtungswaffen
bewaffnete streitkräfte niemals auf dem
gebiet der ehemaligen ddr aufgestellt
werden
[Musik]
all diese bedingungen werden bis heute
von der nato eingehalten bei allen
verhandlungen im jahr 1990 ging es
ausschließlich um den status
deutschlands nicht um mittel und
osteuropa und auch nicht darüber dass
das bündnis nicht erweitert wird
drittens erst nach der auflösung des
warschauer pakts wurde die frage
aufgeworfen wie die sicherheit der
postkommunistischen staaten weiter
gesichert und verankert werden kann aber
es war nicht der westen der das thema
angesprochen hat es waren die politiker
den mitteleuropäischen staaten ist
besondere lech walesa und was hat
gorbatschow selbst räumte ein dass eine
nato-erweiterung wahrscheinlich sei und
sagte er wisse von der absicht einer
reihe von führern osteuropäischer länder
aus dem warschauer pakt auszutreten und
anschließend der nato beizutreten
gorbatschow schlug sogar vor dass die
sowjetunion selbst den nato-beitritt 4
1997 stimmte russland der nato
erweiterung sogar formell zu als es die
so genannte grund aktuell über
gegenseitige beziehungen zusammenarbeit
und sicherheit mit dem bündnis
unterzeichnet in dieser politischen
vereinbarung die das vertrauen zwischen
ost und west stärken und gewohnheiten
der konsultation und zusammenarbeit
etablieren sollte verpflichtete sich die
nato keine nennenswerten kampftruppen
auf dem territorium der ehemaligen
warschauer pakt staaten zu stationieren
die dem bündnis beitreten der damalige
russische präsident boris jelzin wollte
ein russisches veto gegen jede weitere
ausweitung in den vertrag aufnehmen aber
die westlichen staatsoberhaupt weigerten
sich
[Musik]
aber seitdem haben die alliierten in
keinem neuen mitgliedsland das früher im
sowjetischen einflussbereich lag massive
kampftruppen dauerhaft stationiert die
frage ist also wie konnte anders ist
dieser eindeutigen fakten lade
eigentlich den mythos vom versprechen
der nicht erweiterung der nato entstehen
nun erste spekulationen darüber kamen
bereits in der ersten hälfte der 1990 er
jahre auf 1998 formulierte der britische
spezialist für internationale
beziehungen michael mcguire eine
ausführliche hypothese über das
angeblich versprechen einer pufferzone
zwischen der udssr und dem westen ohne
diese durch ausreichende quellen belegen
zu können er rechtfertigte seine
mangelhafte quellenlage damit dass die
aufzeichnungen und notizen der
relevanten gespräche damals noch
unzugänglich waren sobald ihre
geheimhaltung aufgehoben würde käme die
war als schon noch ans licht der punkt
ist die unterlagen sind mittlerweile
öffentlich zugänglich und sie haben
mcquire hypothese nicht bestätigt diese
geistert jedoch nach wie vor ungestört
in russischen nationalistischen kreisen
hören sein text tauchte 2008 wieder auf
als es darum ging die russische
aggression gegen georgien zu
rechtfertigen und im märz 2010 wurde
eine variation dieses themas von putin
erneut verwendet um russland illegal
annexion der krim zu rechtfertigen und
weitere aggressive aktionen gegen die
ukraine vorzubereiten vorbereitete
dieses narrativ bereits seit 2007 vor
als auf der münchner
sicherheitskonferenz die gezielt das
informative frage in den raum was ist
auch den zusicherungen geworden die
unsere westlichen partner nach der
auflösung des warschauer pakts gemacht
haben tja aus diesem sorgsam gesponnene
narrativ schafft seine macht politik bis
heute sowohl nach innen als auch nach
außen und daher stellen sich viele von
euch ganz zu recht die frage warum will
putin jetzt im jahr 2022 wieder die
kriegstrommeln schlagen warum gerade zu
diesem zeitpunkt nun das dann wird uns
jetzt ansehen
mit heruntergelassenen hosen erwischt
[Musik]
russland hat mehr als 100.000 bis an die
zähne bewaffnete soldaten an der
ukrainischen grenze stationiert
inklusive einer staaten panzer an und
zwar seit herbst 2000 21
und hier eine vorstellung davon zu geben
das entspricht einem viertel der
gesamten ukrainischen armee und wir in
früheren politik videos gesehen haben
ist die ukraine nicht in der lage einem
russischen großangriff standzuhalten ja
es stimmt zwei 2014 ist das ukrainische
militär modernisiert worden sie haben
jetzt us waffen und bessere ausbildung
was für eine korrupte armee war die
nicht einmal die mittel dazu hatte um
alle soldaten einzukleiden ist heute
eine viel ernstere angelegenheit doch
ohne die verstärkung der nato ist es für
sie fast unmöglich einem großangriff
stand zu halten im moment sind kaum
truppen mobilisiert worden und es ist
nicht klar ob alle nato mitglieder dazu
bereit wären
also hat russland die situation
ausgenutzt und mit militärisch
technischen vergeltungsmaßnahmen gedroht
falls er seine forderungen nicht erfüllt
werden so sieht es aus im dezember 2021
legte die russische botschaft dem weißen
haus ihre forderungen vor das heißt ihre
bedingungen für die aufnahme von
verhandlungen über einen hypothetischen
truppenabzug es geht um eine reihe von
forderungen die praktisch unvorstellbar
sind als gegenleistung für eine der
eskalation der spannungen verlangt putin
vom westen sicherheitsgarantien dass die
nato nicht weiter nach osten expandiert
und vor allem die finger von der ukraine
lässt natürlich gehört dazu die
forderung dass die nato keine neuen
mitglieder aufnehmen soll muti fordert
auch dass die nato keine übungen mehr in
ihrem östlichen mitgliedsländer
durchführen soll mit anderen worten
russland will einer reihe souveräner
staaten vorschreiben was sie mit ihren
armeen innerhalb ihrer eigenen
landesgrenzen tun können und was nicht
sonst aber nicht nur das russland will
nun mit den usa verhandeln mit anderen
worten sie gehen davon aus dass die nato
kein gesprächspartner ist groß land
ignoriert einfach seine europäischen
nachbarländer und ihre souveränität
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja das ist wohl der gekränkten stolz
eines unreifen und schlechten liebhabers
denn der rest der europäische staaten
die teil des bündnisses sind haben nicht
das geringste interesse an putin aber
darüber werden wir in zukünftigen video
sprechen denn ich alle schon dass das
thema ukraine hier auf so alle politik
viele videos hervorbringen wird denn
jetzt stellt sich die frage was genau
sich putin mit diesen forderungen
erhofft überlegt man es handelt sich um
ein spiel das nur auf lügen basiert
moskau verlangt schriftliche garantien
und wiederholt immer wieder dieselbe
geschichte wie schon oft in der
vergangenheit ihr habt es uns anfang der
1990 er jahre versprochen und eure
versprechen nicht gehalten ihr habt uns
betrogen es ist die gezielte strategie
einer lüge ständig und 30 zu wiederholen
bis sie irgendwann alle glauben im
grunde genommen zeigt russland damit
dass es bereit ist die ukraine ganz oder
teilweise anzugreifen und nicht nur das
es zeigt auch dass es über die nötigen
mittel verfügt um dies zu tun die frage
lautet daher ist dies ein vorwand um
einen krieg zu rechtfertigen nun noch
kennen wie die antwort nicht aber es ist
schwer vorstellbar russland ist nicht an
einem offenen krieg interessiert aber
könnte dies ein weg sein um zu testen
wie weit die nato zu gehen bereit ist
nun diese hypothese macht mehr sinn
vielleicht könnte sie dazu dienen ihre
verhandlungsposition zu verbessern
sie ist doch mal so es macht keinen sinn
dass russland in die gesamte ukraine
einmarschieren will die hälfte des
landes würde sich gegen den eindringling
auf leben und es wird ein langer und
mühsamer zermürbungskrieg werden und du
weißt wie lange und langwieriges
zermürbungskrieg beenden wer nicht fragt
die usa einfach nach ihren erfahrungen
in afghanistan
es wäre jedoch nicht vernünftig zu
denken dass putin die ukraine in zwei
teile spalten bild das heißt dass die
östlichen regionen der sogenannte
dollars zu einer satelliten republik
russlands werden würde wenn man bedenkt
dass die mehrheit der bevölkerung in
diesen gebieten russischsprachige ist
ist das keine abwegige idee andererseits
wäre es nicht das erste mal dass die
ukraine ihre grenzen wieder neu ziehen
muss aber all das sind themen für das
nächste video denn jetzt bist du an der
reihe glaubst du dass wir einen offenen
krieg in der ukraine erleben werden dass
wir eine neue karte der ukraine bekommen
werden mit den republiken donetsk und
lugansk reis unabhängigen ländern oder
glaubst du dass die nato in der lage
sein wird putin aufzuhalten wie immer
sind wir auf seine meinung zu diesem
thema schon sehr gespannt ich hoffe also
dass ihr diese video gefallen hat was ja
gibt uns bitte einen like empfehle ist
ein freund und vergisst nicht das abo
mit glöckchen um keines unserer videos
so verpassen unterstützen unsere arbeit
bitte auch mit einer kleinen spende über
den link in der beschreibung unter
diesem video was gut und bis bald
[Musik]